.
BEN WEDEMAN, CNN, GAZA.
>>> WELL, RUSSIA'S SUPPORT FOR
HAMAS IS PART OF WHAT MANY SEE
AS ITS REGIONAL POWER PLAY.
AND WE ARE SEEING SIMILAR
KREMLIN INFLUENCE OVER THE MAN
DESCRIBED AS EUROPE'S LAST
DICTATOR.
BELORUSSIAN PRESIDENT ALEXANDER
LUKA
LUKASHENKO.
IN HIS FIRST PUBLIC ADDRESS
SINCE HE FORCED A LANDING OF
RYANAIR FLIGHT ON SUNDAY, HE
CLAIMS ILL-WISHES ARE ATTACKING
BELARUS, SPEAKING TO PARLIAMENT
A SHORT TIME AGO THE PRESIDENT
SAID THERE WAS A BOMB THREAT
THAT CAME FROM SWITZERLAND.
SWITZERLAND DENIES ANY KNOWLEDGE
OF THAT.
MR. LUKASHENKO SAYS DIVERTING
THE PLANE WAS LEGAL, BUT THERE'S
PLENTY OF CONDEMNATION COMING
FROM THE U.S. AND THE UK ALONG
WITH THE EU AND THE UNITED
NATIONS.
EUROPE TELLING AIRLINES TO AVOID
BELORUSSIAN AIR SPACE.
CNN'S MATTHEW CHANCE JOINING US
FROM MOSCOW.
FRED PLEITGEN STANDING BY IN
BERLIN.
LET ME START WITH YOU, FRED.
YOU LISTENED TO WHAT LUKASHENKO
SAID.
WHAT ELSE WAS IN THAT SPEECH?
>> Reporter: WELL, IT WAS A MIX
OF LASHING OUT TOWARDS THE WEST,
LASHING OUT AT THE OPPOSITION IN
THE BELARUS BUT THEN ALSO A LOT
OF CLAIMS THAT ARE UNVERIFIED
AND UNVERIFIED UNTIL RIGHT NOW.
HE MADE THE CLAIM THAT THE BOMB
THREAT ALLEGEDLY CAME FROM
SWITZERLAND.
THE SWISS SAYING THEY HAVE NO
KNOWLEDGE OF THAT.
HE ALSO SAID APPARENTLY SEVERAL
AIRPORTS IN THE REGION TURNED
DOWN, NOT ALLOWED THAT PLANE TO
LAND THERE AFTER THE BOMB THREAT
CAME IN.
HE SPECIFICALLY NAMED POLAND
WARSAW AS WELL.
POLISH AUTHORITIES SAID THEY
KNEW NOTHING ABOUT A PLANE
WANTING TO DIVERT INTO THEIR AIR
SPACE AND TOWARDS WARSAW
AIRPORT.
SO A LOT OF CLAIMS THAT ARE
REALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO VERIFY OR,
QUITE FRANKLY, HAVE BEEN PROVEN
NOT TO BE TRUE BY NOW.
LUKASHENKO THEN ALSO DID LASH
OUT AT THE WEST, NAMING THAT THE
WEST WAS TRYING TO STOKE SOME
SORT OF REVOLT IN BELARUS, THAT
AT SOME POINT THEN COULD ALSO
AFFECT RUSSIA AS WELL.
LISTEN TO WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
>> Translator: AS WE PREDICTED,
OUR ILL-WISHERS BOTH OUTSIDE AND
INSIDE THE COUNTRY HAVE CHANGED
THEIR METHODS OF ATTACKING THE
BELORUSSIAN STATE.
THEY HAVE CROSSED A LOT OF
REDLINES AND TRANCE GRESZED THE
LIMITS OF COMMON SENSE AND
COMMON MORALITY.
>> LUKASHENKO AT THE SAME TIME
PROTOSEVICH, THE JOURNALIST AND
CRITIC OF ALEXANDER LUKASHENKO
WAS TAKEN OFF THE PLANE HE
REMAINS IN CUSTODY AND THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY
CONTINUES ITS TOUGH LINE ON
ALEXANDER LUKASHENKO AND HIS
REGIME.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SAYING
THAT SANCTIONS ARE VERY MUCH IN
PLAY.
WHAT WE'RE REALLY SEEING HAPPEN
NOW IN THE SKIES OVER EUROPE
SOME OF THOSE FLIGHT BANS REALLY
SEEMING TO TAKE HOLD.
TAKE A LOOK AT ONE FLIGHT PATH
OF A PLANE SUPPOSED TO FLY FROM
MINCE TO BARCELONA BUT HAD TO
HOLD FOR AROUND TWO HOURS IN
BELORUSSIAN AIR SPACE AND THEN
RETURN BACK TO MINCE.
THERE'S ALSO VERY FEW WESTERN
AIRLINES WHO ARE STILL FLYING
OVER BELORUSSIAN AIR SPACE.
ALSO, THE OPPOSITION LEADER OF
BELARUS WHO OF COURSE IS IN
EXILE, SHE WAS AT THE FOREIGN
RELATIONS COMMITTEE OF THE
EUROPEAN PARLIAMENT TODAY AND
SHE CALLED FOR EVEN TOUGHER
ACTION ON THE PART OF EUROPE
AGAINST THE LUKASHENKO G
GOVERNMENT.
LET'S HAVE A LISTEN.
>> LET'S BE FRANK, THE PREVIOUS
USED STRATEGY OF WAIT AND SEE
TOWARDS THE BELORUSSIAN REGIME
DOESN'T WORK.
THE EU APPROACH OF ELEVATING
PRESSURE ON LUKASHENKO'S REGIME
HASN'T MANAGED TO CHANGE HIS
BEHAVIOR AND ONLY LED TO A
GROWING SENSE OF IMPUNITY AND
MASSIVE REPRESSIONS.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT SHE
WAS ALSO TALKING ABOUT IS SHE
BELIEVES THAT THE EU SHOULD DO
RESTRICT THE IMPORTS OF SOME
GOODS FROM BELARUS, LIKE FOR
INSTANCE, TIMBER AND OIL.
SO AS YOU CAN SEE, BECKY, A LOT
GOING ON.
WE DON'T SEE SO FAR IS ALEXANDER
LUKASHENKO IN ANY WAY, SHAPE OR
FORM BACKING DOWN.
>> YEAH.
FASCINATING.
MATT, WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
U.N.'S SECURITY COUNCIL MEETING
PRIVATELY TODAY ON BELARUS.
U.S. PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN POINTED
OUT SAYS HE'S PREPARING
SANCTIONS.
ALL OF THIS AHEAD OF WHAT IS
THIS NOW CONFIRMED PUTIN/BIDEN
SUMMIT.
I WONDER HOW THIS ISSUE MIGHT BE
ADDRESSED OR MIGHT OVERSHADOW
WHAT IS THIS BUBBLE OF
U.S./RUSSIA RELATIONS AT
PRESENT.
>> Reporter: WELL, I MEAN, NOT
SURE IT'S GOING TO OVERSHADOW IT
BUT LIKELY TO BE ON THE AGENDA
SIMPLY BECAUSE IT'S THE LATEST
IN A LONG LINE OF DIFFERENCES OF
OPINION, IF WE CAN CALL IT THAT,
BETWEEN THE RUSSIANS AND THE
AMERICANS ABOUT A WHOLE RANGE
OF, YOU KNOW, CONDUCT AND GLOBAL
AFFAIRS.
LOOK, WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HOW THE
GLOBAL COMMUNITY AT LARGE AND IN
GENERAL HAS BEEN CONDEMNING
CATEGORICALLY WHAT TOOK PLACE IN
BELARUS.
AND ITS APPARENT VIOLATION OF
INTERNATIONAL NORMS BY FORCING
THAT CIVILIAN AIRLINER DOWN
APPARENTLY WITH THE EXPRESSED
PURPOSE OF DETAINING A DISSIDENT
JOURNALIST AND ACTIVIST ON
BOARD.
BUT THE RUSSIANS AREN'T PART OF
THAT.
THEY'VE BACKED THEIR NEIGHBOR
AND THEIR ALLY TO THE HILT.
THEY'VE SAID JUST TODAY THAT
THEY DON'T SEE ANY REASON TO
DOUBT THE VERSION OF EVENTS AND
I'M PARAPHRASING THEM, TO DOUBT
THE VERSION OF EVENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN PUT OUT BY THE RUSSIANS
WHEN IT COMES TO WHY THEY ASKED
OR DEMANDED THAT THAT PLANE LAND
IN MINSK.
IT WAS A SECURITY THREAT, OF
COURSE, THE BELORUSSIANS SAY, A
BOMB THREAT ON BOARD.
THE RUSSIANS SAY THEY HAVE NO
REASON TO DOUBT THAT.
AND THEY HAVEN'T BEEN CRITICAL
OF THE DETENTION OF THAT
DISSIDENT JOURNALIST AND
ACTIVIST WHO HAS BEEN TAKEN INTO
CUSTODY.
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN CRITICAL OF
THE FACT THAT HIS GIRLFRIEND,
WHO IS A RUSSIAN CITIZEN, HAS
ALSO BEEN TAKEN INTO CUSTODY.
SHE WAS TAKEN OFF THE PLANE AS
WELL AND HAS BEEN REMANDED FOR I
THINK TWO MONTHS BY THE
BELORUSSIAN AUTHORITIES HAVING
BEEN ACCUSED OF VIOLATING SOME
UNSPECIFIED CRIMES IN THE
COUNTRY OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF
YEARS.
AND SO, LOOK, YOU KNOW, FRED
MENTIONED THAT ALEXANDER
LUKASHENKO, THE BELORUSSIAN
PRESIDENT SHOWS NO SIGN OF
BACKING DOWN AND THE MAIN REASON
FOR THAT IS BECAUSE HE DOESN'T
NEED TO.
BECAUSE HE KNOWS MOSCOW HAS HIS
BACK,